Hello and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host David Flanagan and today we
are continuing with the complete guide to Spin.
Continuing on with the real world examples,
today we're gonna take a look at how
we can use Spin
the back end service to speak to a
remote API.
We have to deal with cars, authentication,
key values and even the key value explorer.
Something we haven't seen before in this course.
Our mission is to integrate with the Blue
Sky API.
What we wanna do is grab a post
from Blue Sky, fetch it over the API
and display it on our website.
For that, we're going to use a web
component. Before we dive into how we make
this happen, let's take a look at the
code in action. So we can pop over
here to the browser where we have my
first class UI skills as always. Black text
on a white background.
Here it says the skies are blue.
We can hit refresh, the page reloads
and everything is as we expect. So let's
drop in a blue sky URL.
We have paced. We can see this is
staging.bsky.app
with a post ID, which is a post
from myself. We click embed
and we can see all the details that
we need. Now the UI is not great,
of course,
but we do get my name, my handle,
my profile photo and the contents of the
post itself.
So how do we make this happen?
Well, this is a lit web component.
We can open bluesky.ts
and I'm not gonna spend too much time
on this web component because it's just a
vehicle to show the post all the cool
stuff happens on the back end. But this
web component has some properties with the fields
that we've seen on the UI. The link,
whether it's been fetched or not, my display
name, the avatar,
the handle, and the post. If we pop
down,
we can see we have an input box
and a button. You've seen these too.
We have the ability to render it as
beautifully as I did and then the embed
itself.
The embed link is a remote call to
Fermion Cloud with my back end app ID.
We send a push request, the fact that
we're sending JSON and we send the link.
That's all. Once the information is provided to
the browser, it can be rendered with the
web component.
So let's see how we made this work
with Fermion Spin. Here, I have a back
end directory
which contains all of the code using the
Spin framework.
If we pop open index,
you'll see that I'm using Fermion's TypeScript SDK
for this project, but of course, it's WebAssembly.
I could have used Rust. I could have
used c sharp. I could have used whatever
I want. We specify the input which is
just an interface where we get a link.
We're just using this so that we can
deserialize the input as it comes to our
handle request function.
Now something that we haven't seen a lot
of with our spend project so far is
handling cars.
This is really important when you're providing a
remote API that can be specifically called from
a browser because the minute the browser is
involved,
cross origin request policies
become mandatory.
So we're just making sure that if we
do receive an options request on our Spin
application
that we say, hey. We allow you to
call this from anywhere. We are a public
API.
We're gonna allow you to request a content
type, which could be application JSON,
and we're gonna allow you to send an
options request, which we are responding to as
well as a post request.
Next, we're using the Fermion Cloud key value
store.
Here we use the Spin SDK, we get
the key v namespace and then we open
the default store.
We're doing this because we actually have variables
that we need to persist over time. The
blue sky API
gives us back an access token and a
refresh token
when we authenticate.
We don't want to do this every single
time. That access token may be valid for
an hour, six hours, or even a week.
So store it in a cache and refresh
it as required.
What we do here is we say that
if the off token k v key does
not exist, we're going to go through the
create first session flow
and we'll take a look at that in
a moment.
If anything goes wrong, we return an error.
Assuming that the authentication token was successful,
then we can decode and grab that value
from the key value store and start to
build our blue sky request.
Now this code is not particularly fancy. We're
just splitting the link to grab out the
correct portions to get the handle and the
post ID. As you can see, I'm lettering
all of my code with console dot log
debugging statements.
I can fetch this from Fermion Cloud's UI
to understand what's going wrong when something goes
wrong. It's nice being able to hook into
all the standard print line debugging tools that
we've got experience with over the last one
year, five years, or even twenty years. From
here, we do a whole bunch of nested
awaits to grab the blue sky profile so
that we can get the distributed identifier
for this ID. Don't worry if you're not
familiar with the lexicon of blue sky, but
a dead or a distributed identifier is how
we're able to then make further requests to
the API.
Then we'd nest up our awaits again, this
time using
the XRPC endpoint getPostThread
where we pass
the DID
and the post ID. From here, we have
everything that we need. We can see got
the post, return it to a hundred and
dump it straight back to the user. From
there, it can be displayed. Now there's something
else that we have to go through here
and that is that create first session flow.
If we do not have an access token,
then we need to do the authentication dance.
Again, we pull out a k v store
to make sure that we can get and
set values.
Now we're looking for values to exist here
or else this is never gonna work. Notably,
we need a username and a password for
blue sky.
If those don't exist, we can never log
in. If they do exist, we grab them
and we hit the create session endpoint on
the blue sky API.
If this is successful,
we store the off token as off token
and k v.
Neat. So how do we get that username
and password in to our key value store?
Well, let's take a look at our spend
dot toml. Currently, we're deploying our Blue Sky
API like we do everything else.
We specify the source, we enable the default
key value store
and we make sure that we are allowed
to make HTTP request to the blue sky
dot social API.
However, we've added one additional component to this
deployment and that is the KV explorer,
which is available on the root internal
slash k v dash explorer.
This is an awesome component provided by Radu
from the Fermion team and it gives you
a UI
to browse and set and interact
with your key value store. In fact, if
we come over here, we can browse to
our Fermion cloud URL
and add internal
KV
explorer
and we get this UI. It uses basic
authentication
which is set in the KV itself and
I'll go over how to set that for
the first time in just a moment. But
from here,
I can take a look at my username
and I see that it is Rawkode dot
dev. I could show you the password, but
let's not do that. The credentials for the
KV itself are stored in KV credentials.
Now I don't mention them.
They're Rawkode Rawkode
because I'll delete this application before I publish
the video. And if I don't, have fun.
We then have our off token, which again,
I'm not going to show you as it
will allow you to authenticate and speak to
the Blue Sky API as myself.
But this is very cool. From here, I
can set new keys.
I could say the ABCDEF
equals to 123456
and click add.
We can view the value and delete it
if we wish.
This is a really neat component to add
just to make your lives a little bit
easier when you're getting things set up. But
how do we set that initial key value
credential?
Let's go back to the CLI
where we could do a spend deploy. However,
before we do the spin deploy, we're gonna
modify it where we're gonna say key value
k v credentials equals
and I will set this to Rawkode
password. Now if you recall when I showed
you my credentials, they were Rawkode Rawkode.
Now when we do the deploy, this will
override the value and this is the best
way and the easiest way to set it
on that first deploy.
So let's click the link
And now we have to log in again
and we'll say Rawkode
password,
like so. We can view the credentials and
even delete them. Perfect.
So there you have it. A real world
component to integrate with the Blue Sky API.
We take a look at handling course request
with Fermion endpoints,
leveraging the key value store
even at runtime to store our authentication token
and a wonderful component to browse and explore
the key value store making your debugging life
that little bit easier. So go forth, have
some fun.
Spin is evolving at a crazy pace and
these videos will continue to come showing you
everything that you need to know to be
successful with Vermillion Spin. Have a great day.